[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
they got in coincidence in our town
which was cool yeah he used to work at
the bed bath and beyond that's was you
had a bed bath and beyond yeah it's
pretty bougie store
yeah it was in slot it was in um
slidell which is like the town here
that's my dude we should go camp out at
the mall we would go there go to the
mall
and then camp in a tent outside and go
back in the next day why yeah just to be
at the mall man the mall was sick the
mall was good
did you enjoy your childhood
i think i did in hindsight it was just
scary i felt like it was scary because
like a lot of dangerous kind of whites
and dangerous blacks i felt like i was
also like real scared
so i think i was like scared of
everything you know but i was also like
you know
and i could do anything i wanted there
was nobody keeping
you know like you know i was supposed to
drink milk and [ __ ] be alive for like
15 years like that was like kind of the
[ __ ] guidance no one took care of you
yeah there was just no like
like everything was like yeah it was
just kind of like
nobody ever checked in to see what was
going on it was just [ __ ]
it was like somebody started me at the
top of a hill
i may check in with you sometime
but in high tide it was fun you know
yeah and i think there's also going to
be some disconnect there's okay letting
poor people struggle here because i
think on the back of our heads we're
like yo we need more 30 for 30s
to be honest with you yo europe got the
trash of 30 30s bro
they should have had way better ones but
they don't their 30 30s was like
christopher columbus yeah
like their 30 30s was like joan of arc
you know what i mean if you go back a
thousand years bro their 30 for 30s were
lit louis the [ __ ] 13th or whatever
like the 14th baby 14th 13th dude [ __ ]
dude 13th had asthma and they killed him
for it
bro dude
show up right up that hill you better
show up with both bags working baby
one bag and a dog they took that dude's
life
what was he doing who was so strenuous
who knows he's the king that's the best
job
yo why don't you get me that
really often with a head no dude you
gotta [ __ ] be able to finish the line
son you've got to finish the whole yeah
you got to be out of focus off of the
head that's right one breath oh yeah
single breath bro yeah
yeah yeah we don't want it
out of here bruh yeah
that was it dog dude we should have a
castle bro fire ass 30 for 30 from back
in the day we should have a castle
i learned from there like the the value
of giving like how fulfilling that [ __ ]
can be like yeah really help just just
giving someone something yeah how
[ __ ] good that can make you feel oh
yeah it's like i come from new york
which is a taker city it's like how can
i [ __ ] you over how can i swindle you
how can i get you and the second
swindler's list right windler's
manhattan
dude manhattan new york bro tell me this
about new york let's be honest alphabet
city the only place you can even get you
can't even get mugged in [ __ ] new
york anymore how sad is that bro i know
you can't even get [ __ ] stabbed
unless you [ __ ] you know fall into a
silverware dealer down in alphabet city
yeah it's all about that's the only
place bro everything else is so [ __ ]
expensive dude it's so expensive it's so
crazy nice you gotta go far to be in
trouble yeah you gotta go really far and
that's changed man back i remember when
i first went there you know 15 20 years
ago i ended up in a cab and a threesome
with [ __ ] some of the guys from oh
town no no yeah which one oh out of
black or who knows he looked black that
was the black guy
there's not a lot of people out there
telling stories anymore
it's almost like in hollywood everything
gets so like chopped down i feel like a
lot of times that they don't let you
tell the good story or even the true
story
like you can't tell a story like and you
can't tell a story a lot of even true
stories about like race and stuff
sometimes because they act like
sometimes as a white person if you say
the word black or if you say it or if
you say something about like like two of
my best black friends got killed by
other black guys right yeah so i don't
like
that [ __ ] makes me mad right when i see
a lot of stuff like first 48 and those
type of shows where there's a lot of
black on black crime and you see
there's white people making money off
the show i'm sure whoever you follow the
makers of the show yeah it's going to
get a little fun he's not going back
into the community
it's not right right right it's not
going into [ __ ] memphis and let's
just say memphis okay i think memphis
needs it
they're just going i hope someone gets
murdered in this 48-hour period because
that's what the show is there's a
producer of that show that is going to
work every week going i hope someone
gets murdered jesus christ that's a
tough way to oh damn it's easter [ __ ]
it's always slow around this time of
year you know what i'm saying yeah dude
groundhog's day we're gonna have another
three weeks of winter or whatever yeah
but i just like i feel like sometimes
it's like if i say
that
man i feel like sometimes it's just it
scares me how much black on my crime
there is that people think that i'm
against like like i want black people to
live and prosper i don't it's not like i
might then think it's a like that black
people are bad does that make any sense
yeah i think that the tricky thing with
that is just like
all crime is usually committed within
the same race because most people just
live around their race right so i think
the term to a lot of people is like well
black and black crimes and white on
white crime like white people are
murdering white people like all these
serial killers often are just murdering
white chicks like you watch any of these
documentaries just a white dude
murdering white chicks that's not white
on white crime that's easy too let's be
honest dude dude was so easy where's the
white dude murdering black chicks bro
that
that right there
that right there that would be hard to
do [ __ ] tuskegee airmen
you need like you need
german yeah you need a plate
you're gonna need a plane all these
serial kills are [ __ ] bro you're just
going after white chicks go to the hood
richard ramirez [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
yeah
that's true these black chests are
fighting back
i got now i got them we got them
they had this mic girl in my class
growing up i could not breathe deep
without this chick seeing me from across
the [ __ ] class like she just always
had a beat on whatever i was doing i
think she thought i could maybe you know
just end up being a crazy person
so i just anytime i even like would be
like
i [ __ ] noticed you [ __ ] yes yes
we're not shooting at the school today
theo no
no
[Laughter]
no i moved to china i started looking
like one of the days
i get i i will get a little bit chinese
yes i'll start to kind of yeah i'll do
just little things that i see them do i
struggle a little bit yeah first i start
to do it i move quickly [ __ ] on the
sidewalk yeah yeah dude i'll do it take
a [ __ ] on the sidewalk sit down coughing
in my [ __ ] child's mouth
so it doesn't get out into the air but
they'll do that kind of stuff bro the
chinese dog let's let's be honest about
the chinese like that's one thing i
don't like sometimes it's like america
we have to make every moment in america
acceptable for everyone in some magical
[ __ ] way yeah bro you go to [ __ ]
dude i went to a bar i went to china
they don't give up bro you die in china
they make a [ __ ] soup out of you they
feed the [ __ ] people are hungry bro
yeah [ __ ] moves on dog [ __ ] i mean and
they'll do that in an eight minute set
bruh definitely feel excited i
definitely yeah it's definitely been
totally different just having people
come out after like 15 years doing shows
and people finally come out it's just
you know it's different and my thing is
i've just been like i want everything to
be okay it's like when somebody comes
over to your house yeah even the cops
are coming over here they're coming you
want to [ __ ] clean up yeah
it's like that's kind of how i feel like
people are coming over you know let's
[ __ ] make sure all like the [ __ ]
candles are lit yeah i just got my first
stripe the other day at jiu jitsu oh are
you doing jiu jitsu yeah i got two i
think i have two cracked like two
cracked ribs right now which one of the
reasons i've been able to go but uh this
week but i just got my first strike and
you enjoy the exercise yeah it's really
fun everybody tries it loves it
yeah i like it it's just it's tough on
your body it's a little bit tough really
yeah i had five they've been having i've
fought women i've thought
a guy who is legally blind last they got
me fighting in the real
you know it's not even a weight class
it's almost like an emotional wellness
group you know
like i'm like what weight class that i'm
in they're like jiu jitsu
yeah like what weight glass i'm in like
you're over there behind the water
fountain okay
so it's a unique group man once we got
here we're like yo castles are hard to
build like [ __ ] stone i think that's
what america really broke away from
europe to do
just build [ __ ] out of wood yeah yeah
that's not a bad thought that's stone
[ __ ]
it looks cool
but it's heavy dog
it's heavy but then think about the
manliness back then you know we soft now
people got pvc pipe it used to be used
to have to fill your mouth up and
[ __ ] put in your next buddy's mouth
you know what i'm saying old school
plumbing bro you know what i'm talking
about speak for yourself dog solo's
riley do you have any questions for this
gentleman
uh i do not
thanks raleigh
dude appreciate it i'm telling you kids
now bro it's a whole different ball and
i know everything right we got
no that's not the dude
unbelievable what happened the other day
you didn't know riley what was it on
that episode um
you don't remember i don't remember but
it's all good imagine an asian person
saying they don't remember yeah i know
when is that happening it's bad is it
american bro that's another thing we
have here's the thing that happens in
america people come from another country
okay they're like we all better
you we're gonna force these kids to
learn spanish so we can communicate with
these newcomers the second generation of
newcomers knows no [ __ ] spanish
they get american real quick we flip
people real quick dude at all
real quick son one generation you
american you guys are bad friends
you want some let's go
i think we're good you i'm great hey can
we both do it at the same time let's do
it all right one two three we're bad
friends oh
okay there we go
let's pull up one more question man
before we let this beautiful fella get
off the hook man what else we got here
uh
um
[ __ ] i don't even know this guy's name
man raleigh male here comes a young
fella right here
what up theo what up schultzy gosh got a
quick question for you
know you both are
new to ufc and
want to see which one of y'all
superstars would uh win
if y'all did a tag team match
theo and dustin
or sultsy in israel
i'll beat that baby's ass i'll say this
dude and no offense man beautiful child
bro dude
i'll tell you this nobody picks being
friends with better ufc fighters
bro thank you yeah
you can spot talent
[Music]
of all the [ __ ] guys out there who
look like they've been attacked by
[ __ ] dogs and we pick some [ __ ]
kings that's a great ass point man
that's a good point man
yeah i don't know that one i mean it's
tough
that one's tough man because uh
you know theo's got theo's got his super
powers bro like if you go full rat king
it might be a short day of work you know
what i mean cause we got rabies baby uh
you might you might gnaw on me or you
know you might do something i just don't
know how to combat that at all so you
might take me out but then izzy might
have an advantage over dustin just
because of the size yeah
so it it might it's tricky bro it's a
really tricky one man like that's people
got to realize like this is a good
podcast man i just realized this is fun
this is fine
[Music]
[Music]
just the wrong way
[Music]